exclusive interview with george
papadapolis and his wife simona but
that's for coming up later first
tonight's breaking news opening
monologue hard to believe but 17 years
ago today we were attacked like never
before right here on American soil
all told 2,977 innocent men and women
and children lost their lives at the
hands of pure evil in our lifetime
fulfilling what they think is their evil
ideology designed by an evil man by the
name of Osama bin Laden now some of the
finest people on earth were senselessly
killed good hard-working people in the
World Trade Center first responders
police over 300 firemen while everybody
was rushing down they rushed into those
burning towers many others in the
Pentagon the passengers the crew of the
planes that were brutally hijacked and
used as weapons of war including the
brave men and women on flight 93 they
fought back against their attackers
let's roll
causing that plane to crash in a remote
field in Pennsylvania miles away from
what we believe was their intended
target in Washington DC
today President Trump visited a
brand-new monument honoring those brave
American souls and he delivered these
powerful remarks let's take a look
all of America wraps up and joins
together we close our arms to help you
shoulder your pain and to carry your
great great sorrow your tears are not
shed alone for they are shared grief
with an entire nation we grieve together
for every mother and father sister and
brother's son and daughter who was
stolen from us at the Twin Towers the
Pentagon and here in this Pennsylvania
field we honor their sacrifice by
pledging to never flinch in the face of
evil and to do whatever it takes
to keep America safe tonight as we honor
all those who lost their lives 17 years
ago today we must never forget the
danger of radical Islamic terrorism is
real it is always lurking they are they
were at war with us we were not at war
with them we better be prepared and we
better accept that sad but true reality
meanwhile one particularly unhinged
well MSNBC conspiracy TV morning host
seems to have really forgotten just how
devastating 9/11 2001 was yeah good old
liberal Joe put out a new op-ed he put
in the Washington Post it's entitled
Trump is harming the dream of America
more than any foreign adversary ever
could
yesterday the day before 9/11 literally
he's promoting this absurd article and
he sends out a tweet it reads quote my
latest trump is damaging the dream of
America more than any terrorist attack
ever could and according to the tweet
and that op-ed Joe Scarborough thinks
Trump is worse than 9/11 where we lost
nearly 3,000 people
yeah the economy's turned around Joe
people have jobs 4 million fewer people
on food stamps 4 million new jobs are
created really that's how low you're
gonna sink you know sometimes I
literally hang there's no net underneath
me right now this is a live show I do
three hours of live radio every day
sometimes you could say things and they
come out wrong as Congress would say
revise extend our remarks some things
could be an unintentional slip of the
tongue this was a thought-out written
piece he spent time thinking of this and
today on his dumpster fire of a morning
show he doubled down on stupid watch
this if you strip America of its ideas
forget about knocking down buildings in
the financial district forget about
running planes into the Pentagon those
are tragedies but those tragedies bring
us closer together
America is an idea you gut America of
that idea mm-hmm that's when you do the
most harm the retweeting of neo-nazi
videos Charlottesville
I mean I can go on and on what he said
about majority black countries that is
tearing more at the fabric of America
then attacks on the Twin Towers did we
we built from that we became stronger
because of that but this is seems to me
a far graver graver threat to the idea
of America hey Joe kids grew up without
their fathers and mothers and after
facing much backlash for his absurd
comparison liberal Joe he partially
tried to backtrack his well-thought-out
quote column and said that he should
have shown more care in wording his
tweet and then his blushing bride-to-be
fellow host Mika Brzezinski vigorously
defends him on Twitter of course America
is you know cutest couple Joe a mica
perfect example of what happens when
Trump derangement syndrome gets way out
of control
at this point I don't even think these
two can ever recover
it's that sick will deal more with this
later but we now have some very
important breaking news tonight
literally minutes ago Sarah Carter
handed us brand-new never-before-seen
unearthed text once again between FBI
lovebirds struck and Paige why don't
they just hand them all over
it's September 2016 months before the
election it appears struck and Paige
were working or contributing to an op-ed
about Russian election interference look
at your screen right there September 2nd
Lisa Paige asked struck quote but we are
still writing the op-ed yes struck then
response yes ish and on September 5th
2016 the Washington Post they published
the story about Russian interference on
the very same day Sarah Carter reporting
tonight the former FBI lovebirds share a
link to an article struck rights just
read the article we see a lot of the
same things I guess that's okay
and then page rights back quote yeah but
that's why ours is going to need to be
more folksy so it's not like a news
article maybe the talk may be like more
smelly wall more people as struck it
said that and these new text to what
we'll use release yesterday from
congressman mark meadows in North
Carolina you have a pretty clear picture
what's going on including this text from
struck to pay
took place on April 10 2017 reading
quote I had literally just gone to find
this phone to tell you what I want to
talk to you about immediately strategy
with the DOJ before you go oh FBI and
DOJ colluding and in two days later on
April the 12th struck Warren Lisa Paige
that too damning articles were coming
out about her namesake Carter Paige and
then on April 22nd we originally
believed this was on April the 12th
Meadows office corrected that earlier
today same point though Peter struck
tells Lisa Paige quote articles how well
done Paige this is what we've now been
telling you what is a coordinated effort
the highest levels of the FBI and the
DOJ leaking anti-trump information
before the election after the election
to the press first to stop him from
becoming president then to destroy his
presidency but sneaky Peter struck he's
now trying to actually put out his own
conniving spin on this fresh new scandal
his attorney says the term media leak
strategy mr. struck stacks refers to a
department-wide initiative to detect and
stop leaks to the media the president
and his enablers are once again peddling
unfounded conspiracy theories to mislead
the American people
oh but our words sound exactly alike
we're gonna have to make it more folksy
don't insult our intelligence this is
the same Peter struck who claimed under
oath that political bias didn't impact
his work as an FBI agent but Hillary
should win a hundred million to nothing
now the same super Patriot who played a
critical role in exonerating Hillary
Clinton we know she committed felonies
and fomenting this witch-hunt from the
get-go against Donald Trump while
trashing Trump on his work phone openly
wishing Hillary would win the election
how could anyone vote for Trump I just
was in a Walmart smelly Walmart people
were there I could smell the Trump
supporters and earlier today the
president responded on Twitter quote so
terrible nothing being done at the DOJ
or FBI but the world is watching and
they get it completely we did reach out
to struck page in the DOJ we've yet to
get a response we'll have more on these
breaking news developments Sarah and
Greg will join us in a few minutes but
we shift our focus so what is the most
important midterm election of your life
now I'm gonna say this for the next 56
days
last night I called on you to wake up
pay attention Republicans to be very
blunt because I only tell you the truth
they're in real danger of losing the
House of Representatives and the Senate
I'm not that comfortable about that
either look at your screen if that is
your district you will likely decide the
fate of this country in 56 days
Democrats win these races the Trump
agenda will be stopped it will halt
right in its tracks all the progress
we've been telling you about the
Democrats their insane quest for
impeachment will begin in earnest just
listen to Chuck and in Maxine Waters the
Senate frankly also up for grabs
Republicans lose the Senate you can
forget about constitutional as judges
getting confirmed it won't happen and
meanwhile right here on this program we
have long warned that it's only a matter
of time before the aggressive
threatening rhetoric and tactics coming
from the left has got a result
somebody's going to get hurt or killed
here's kind of what I'm talking about
take a look I will go and take Trump out
tonight I have thought an awful lot
about blowing up the White House of
course I want to punch him in the face
[Music]
please get up in the face of some
Congress people I just don't even know
why there aren't uprisings all over the
country maybe there will be getting
their face
Chace Sarah Sanders Pam Bondi secretary
Neilson out of restaurants just say
anything horrible about the first lady
the first daughter even a
twelve-year-old kid over the weekend
well someone did in fact get in the face
of a Republican congressional candidate
guy's name is Rudy Peters never heard of
him before but he's running as a
Republican in California's 25th district
guess what he was approached at a
campaign booth by a man who is making
disparaging remarks about the Republican
Party
well that deranged individual then pulls
out a switchblade and attempted to stab
Peters but the nice thankfully
malfunction and then they had a
confrontation I've said it a million
times before I'll say it again the
tactics of the anti Trump resistance
have gone way too far and while Peters
was able to escape unharmed and I always
blame people for what they do you can't
blame people's rhetoric for what
people's actions are but you've got to
admit this is not helping the next
victim might not be so lucky but if it
was a conservative oh they go nuts
blaming Oh talk radio in the Fox News
Channel I'm now holding individuals
responsible but the rhetoric is reckless
it is dangerous and it's out of control